If there's one thing The Walking Dead has
proven over its run, it's that no one is safe.
From Lori's disturbing demise to the gruesome
fates of Abraham and Glenn, the AMC series
has made it pretty clear that in Robert Kirkman's
zombie apocalypse, the stakes are high.
One character that has felt untouchable through
all of it has been Rick Grimes.
From the day he woke up in that Georgia hospital,
Rick has beaten the odds quite a bit.
On the heels of Carl's passing, though, it
looks like the show on the verge of an overhaul,
and now it's been reported that after season
9, Andrew Lincoln will leave the series that
made him a household name.
So, how might the end of the Ricktatorship
impact the show moving forward?
Here's what Lincoln's departure probably means
for The Walking Dead.
New leadership
Viewership for The Walking Dead has been on
a steady decline since the show hit its peak
in Season 5, and one of the reasons may be
Rick himself.
Over the past few years, we've watched as
Rick repeatedly led the group from one new
home to another, only to find that the humans
there are more dangerous than zombies.
Along the way, he's had some very repetitive
struggles with morality that saw him make
terrible choices, then redeem himself, and
eventually do it all over again.
At this point, it's pretty predictable, and
some viewers also think it's a little boring.
Rick's primary motivation to stay in charge
has always been to protect Carl, so now that
he's out of the picture, it's only natural
that the sheriff might finally step aside
and let someone else take point and that person
might just be Daryl Dixon.
AMC may be positioning the crossbow-wielding
motorcycle enthusiast to take over as top
dog.
Reports say that actor Norman Reedus is negotiating
a sweet new deal with the network that'll
give him top billing for the series as a whole.
Daryl has long been a reliable, capable fan
favorite on the show, and since he never appeared
in Robert Kirkman's comics, the sky's the
limit as to what he can achieve.
Of course, it may be hard to imagine how a
character who's been so quiet and restrained
for all this time can start barking orders
at everybody, but maybe he'll be the kind
of guy who leads by example instead.
Fractured group
As the bloody battle between Rick and Negan
came to its long-awaited conclusion, a new
conflict emerged: Maggie, Daryl, and
Jesus had formed a secret alliance with the
end goal of taking down Negan, against Rick's
wishes.
"Rick was wrong to do what he did.
Michonne, too."
Alexandria and its allies will be dealing
with a fair share of internal conflict in
the coming episodes, with Negan smiling and
swearing on the sidelines.
What role he'll play during this civil war
remains to be seen, but it may be the catalyst
to both Rick and Maggie leaving, since Lauren
Cohan is expected to leave the series in the
coming season as well.
With both of the show's de facto leaders on
their way out, and Negan still around causing
everyone problems, we can expect the culmination
of this growing family feud to be pretty spectacular.
Unless…
New baddies
In the finale's final moments, after showing
leniency to Negan and his Saviors, Rick spoke
of "a new beginning."
Die-hard comic fans know that means a new
threat is probably on its way.
Next season is expected to begin after a two-year
time jump, and if it's anything like Kirkman's
"A New Beginning" comics arc, we can expect
to meet the Whisperers sooner than later.
Negan's violent acts pushed the envelope for
what can be done on TV, but his brutality
may be nothing compared to these people.
And their introduction might just give Negan
the opportunity to redeem himself.
If season 9 does end up delivering on the
civil war storyline, it may be possible that
Negan could prove himself useful.
Is it possible that Negan could team up with
Rick, or even Daryl once these Whisperers
make themselves known?
Stranger things have happened.
Lone wolf
Another consequence of the potential "New
Beginning" storyline is that Michonne may
start going it alone again in the new episodes.
In the comics, following the All-Out War with
Negan, Michonne pretty much ran away from
the group to live out in Oceanside.
While that sounds like more of a Carol move,
it's not out of the question that Michonne
could separate herself from the rest of the
Alexandria gang if Rick is gone.
After all, when we first met her, the only
company she kept was a pair of jawless walkers.
Rick is the first person she's been romantically
involved with since the trauma of losing her
boyfriend and son.
Their relationship added new layers to the
series, giving them both a welcome sense of
hope and purpose.
Without Carl to mother, or Rick to comfort,
we might just see Michonne trade in her samurai
sword for a fishing rod after all.
Rebrand time
After eight seasons, a lot of viewers have
tuned out simply because there's only so much
misery and grief a person can take from their
entertainment.
The network may finally be catching on to
that because losing Carl didn't just spark
the events that transpired in the back half
of season 8, it also set up The Walking Dead
for a major rebrand effort.
Writer Scott Gimple told The Hollywood Reporter:
"Story-wise, we knew we were going to be here.
[...] It allows for a new voice to be telling
new stories, and really resets the show in
a lot of ways."
The voice he's referring to is incoming showrunner
Angela Kang, who'll take over in the new season.
Gimple's pivot from showrunner to chief content
officer is not only a change of the guard
behind the camera, it alludes to a new look,
feel, and strategy for the long-running series.
"You have to write a character point of view
as if you absolutely believe that to be the
truth."
So, perhaps the new creative direction will
also mean the mood will swing in a direction
more fans can stomach every week.
We'll see.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!